he took
it out the fcot tuesday edition chris
sims mike florio getting to some things
that we either talked about during pft
live or didn't talk about or talked
about a little bit and would like to
talk about some more and that's where we
start today cam newton's destination we
had the odds
via
i think it was fanduel for where cam
newton will play the patriots were the
favorite the jaguars
uh the uh the next team on the list
teams like the steelers pop up there
um and and chris you know we we were
talking about the patriots
i don't see it
scott pioli the former vp of player
personnel a few weeks ago said that
there's just a
philosophical or as you would say
philosophical wise clash between bill
belichick and cam newton belichick is
football football football cam newton is
football slash entertainment slash icon
slash things other than football but
still a really good football player i
don't know that that is an
irreconcilable difference between the
two but the bigger picture is
they're set with stidhum they don't have
the cap space to sign cam newton and we
still don't know why not cam newton's
healthy and i think from bill
belichick's perspective he wants to know
even though the train can't move yet i
think he wants to know who's going to be
on the train and he's got his guys on
the train
patiently awaiting the opportunity for
the train to start rolling
yeah well i mean i agree with everything
you said mike i just don't see cam
newton being a fit there in new england
and even though i mean we know new
england's got a bunch of geniuses on the
coaching staff and certainly can
formulate some offense around cam newton
you know i think this is something that
would have been done already by now
because they would have started
attacking free agency in the draft to
fill a certain need to run the cam
newton type of offense that's going to
be different than jared said of new
england just you know again in in my
history working there and playing for
josh mcdaniels with the denver broncos
there is a philosophical
belief in building your team and framing
it around the quarterback and what you
want to be going into that year and i
think the patriots have already started
down
jairus stood um the general of our ship
and we're putting the pieces around him
to make that formula work the right way
and that's where it's interesting with
cam newton i mean it's just amazing
again carolina screwed over cam newton
they screwed him over and now it is
going to be very tough for him to find a
team because
nobody's going to want to bring cam
newton as the backup when they every day
the team's going to walk off the field
going damn our backup looks a lot better
than our starter damn our backup is
throwing lasers everywhere today damn
our backup can move and run around and
that's just going to cause problems
within the locker room and teams are
going to be wary of that
and i agree with you that they did screw
him in that they tried too hard to get
something of value in return via trade
they waited too long they should have
realized they weren't going to get
anything they should have cut him it was
a bad look but how different would the
outcome have been for cam newton if he
had been cut in february he can't pass a
physical now you know what how it would
have been different i'm kind of talking
myself through this if you're cutting
back when you cut if you cut him when
you cut greg olsen
then you can
you can check him out now that's no
guarantee he was going to pass a
physical but he at least would have had
a chance to get into some facilities and
get examined before the world turned
upside down not that anyone really knew
what was coming but he at least would
have had a few weeks to start a free
agency tour go visit some teams get a
physical taken and see where he is so
maybe he would have had a team before
the facilities all slammed shut in early
march so i answered my own question just
by kind of thinking out loud other teams
that were identified we talked about the
patriots the jaguars we talked about
during the show
you and i both believe they're not as
sold on gardner minshew the second as
maybe they want us all to think they are
and i think part of that is selling to
the fans gardner minshew jerseys gardner
minshew gear they love what gardner
minshew brings from a marketing
perspective even if they haven't fully
fallen in love chris with what he can do
as a quarterback
no i mean and that's a very real aspect
of this conversation too i mean they see
potential they see a fan base that
rallied around a player that you know
uh
has a look and a style about him that
just resonates with everybody there so
there is value in that
but i would just still say too
i mean let's not forget we did bench
gardner minshew last year at one point
and brought nick foles back in and cam
newton was the mvp of football just four
years ago
that's to me where you know again if i'm
jacksonville and i start to
get through the off season here and
start to get wind that cam newton is
healthy and maybe we can get a physical
on them
i would think they're going to revisit
this conversation i mean yeah gardner
minshew is gonna sell tickets and and
and jerseys i think cam newton's gonna
sell more of them i do especially there
now the other question too was mike does
you know the new coaching staff there's
a guy like jay gruden does he want a guy
like cam newton to be his quarterback
does he fit within that style of offense
you know maybe they feel like they're
going to be too far down the road to
make that type of move and win and
minchu fits that west coast system
better than than cam newton maybe they
do
but i would also like to think jay
gruden's creative enough to find ways to
make it work with with cam newton
and if any veteran players in
jacksonville would like to get traded
just go public and say you want cam
newton instead of gardner minshew
yeah it probably wouldn't work for
yannick
way but it definitely worked for leonard
fournette but uh you know i think from a
basic fundamental who is better when
healthy i i think it's foolish to say
that gardner minshew was better than cam
newton of course cam newton would be
better the question is can he get
healthy can he stay healthy can you
afford him from a cap standpoint and how
long is he going to be
the answer is it a short limited window
is he a guy that's going to be around
for five or seven years but you know
it's a year to your proposition in the
nfl and until you have that young
quarterback chris that you fully and
firmly believe in why not go get a
veteran who who has proven he can get it
done if he's available
yeah no doubt about it plus i mean again
i do think his skill set would fit with
the talent they have around him in
jacksonville you know you know again
it's
jay gruden yes jay gruden likes to run
the football he has a pretty good
inventory of play-action passes you talk
about leonard fournette and then you get
into the receiver component with them
with you know uh
dj shark and dd westbrook and some other
under the radar talented receivers they
have there i do think he's his skill set
would fit the team and the way doug
marone wants to play you know i think
doug wants to play defense run the
football he's an xo line coach and old
lineman himself controlled the ball that
way so there is some certain value i
think to what cam newton could bring to
the table there so jacksonville is the
one that jumps out to me the most mike
youtube brought up pittsburgh steelers
on the show and i again i think there's
a lot of thought there too to where i i
like what you said you know ben
roethlisberger is getting to the age
where it's a little scary an injury like
that is a little scary too we saw jake
delrome have that same injury and never
really quite be the same guy
uh and if i'm the steelers and mike
tomlin and kevin colbert and you know
people kind of sometimes put their their
their butts on the hot seat i'm going
man i'm not letting big ben get hurt get
me fired here i'm not going to let mason
rudolph or duck hodges get me fired
either i'm going to bring cam newton
onto this team because if big bad does
get hurt we think we have a super bowl
contender and then we still have a super
bowl contending type quarterback
yeah i think you have to wait until
roethlisberger gets hurt to do it i
don't think newton in the building with
roethlisberger is going to be good for
anyone no it would be if it would happen
if it would happen
the four teams of the afc north would
all have heisman winning quarterbacks
joe burrow baker mayfield lamar jackson
and cam newton so uh not that i want to
see ben roethlisberger anywhere but
under center for the steelers but i
think that makes the most sense for cam
newton other teams that are on this list
of odds from fanduel and again it's
patriots one minus 190 jaguars plus 300
steelers plus 750 then it gets up to
four digits the broncos at plus a
thousand i would not take a flyer on
that one drew lock is their guy unless
something happens to drew lock he
retires
right or has some sort of a freak
virtual workout injury if he injures his
thumb while trying to hook up his
computer so he can participate in a
meeting with pat shurmur drew lock is
the guy in denver they are not bringing
cam newton to denver chris under any set
of circumstances other than drew lock
like i said retiring
no exactly right you know they're in the
process of what we're seeing you know
giving drew lock the the type of
artillery around him that's to make that
offense explosive and yeah they're
they're too far down the line now and
you have something big time in drew
locke i think he showed both you and me
and i'm sure john elway that whoa this
kid could be something this is he should
have been drafted in the first round
last year he was a first round talent
he's another case of a guy mike where if
he came out the year before where he led
college football and touchdown passes he
was going to be a top 15 pick but guess
what happened the team fell apart and we
blamed him you know gosh he couldn't
block catch play defense and coach the
team guess we can't take him in the
first round so yeah i'm with you there's
no way that happens that's what's
amazing about this where the hell does
it happen i don't know if i've ever seen
anything like this with this high
caliber of a type player where we go
like holy cow he might have to sit out
the start of the year and truly just
wait for an injury or just relegate
himself and not take a lot of money and
put himself in a good situation to be
the backup and and hope something
happens to them when he takes over can
be positive but i don't see that
happening
yeah i don't think cam's gonna want to
be the backup anywhere and i don't think
he should be the backup anywhere if he's
healthy the bears are plus 1100 that
ship has sailed they traded for nick
falls they're not gonna go get cam
newton that's over maybe they would have
done it before they're not doing it now
the raiders at plus 1500 that may not be
a bad but but what do you do you got
derek carr you got marcus mariota what
do you do now look it's not all that
expensive to move on from derek carr
he's only got like 2 million or so in
guaranteed salary this year but what
what what would cause you now
i i don't know if they could all of a
sudden
i mean i don't know maybe john gruden's
got a trick up his sleeve maybe john
gruden is waiting for the facilities to
open so they can fly cam newton to las
vegas so they can make sure he's healthy
and if he's healthy do they take him
over derek carr i mean if he's healthy
i'd take him over derek carr would you
yes yes i would yeah i mean cam newton's
a special game-changing type talent that
the stats will never justify the total
value of what he brings to the table on
a game by game basis he's a game changer
defenses have to change the way they
play defense when cam newton's on the
field this is what we've talked about a
lot right mike this is the special thing
this is why he's undefeated against the
new england patriots because they start
going damn bill starts going damn i
can't play some of the things i want to
play because i got to worry about
certain things this guy does to a
defense and now i'm out of my comfort
zone there
but yeah i would take him but i don't
think that's going to happen either i
think they're too far down the road and
i think they're going to give derek carr
his chance here with some talent to see
if he can totally justify being that guy
for the future
i would just love to see the images of
john gruden on his tippy toes trying to
talk to cam newton because
uh let's just say there's a significant
height difference
john green and cam newton because cam
newton is a giant and uh john gruden
isn't do you think that that would work
that the cam newton john gruden
relationship would work since you were
at one point on the other end of the
wrath of rudin on a regular basis
i do i do i think it could work yeah i
mean gruden again he's very creative and
smart he does believe in running the
football as we've seen he does have a
deep deep playbook of play action passes
and things like that you know i i think
that gordon would you know
if derek carr wasn't there i i do think
that this would be something they would
have thought about and i do think it
would work gruden loves these type of
guys that are game changers like that
you know what guys like cam newton do
and i can totally picture gruden too
like hey big soldier how do you like
this play big soldier you like this play
you love football you know that's that's
what he would be talking to cam newton
like but uh i do think he would respect
the game-changing ability that cam
newton does have and for an offensive
coordinator you know like leica gruden
where cam newton is so special is he
simplifies defenses because you do have
to worry about the quarterback design
runs and being outnumbered in certain
plays and running schemes and certain
things like that to where now
when you drop back to pass sometimes you
go man we're gonna get to throw this
pass play against this basic defense or
this you know this coverage because
they're worried about the run game whoa
this is a kid in the candy store type
look and that's some of the value he
brings to the table and i think would
excite any offensive game designer
all right before we go i want to revisit
one last time although i may regret this
our effort to identify the 10 or 11
relevant teams currently in the nfl this
is a rule of thumb that sean payton
shared during the draft-a-thon over the
weekend
and it's not easy to identify
that full list the first six or seven
easy we established that those last few
are a little more difficult chris i
think the first niner like let's just
say this i think there's nine that you
and i would agree on right for sure
when we go
when we go chiefs pats ravens
seahawks steelers
eagles saints packers that's eight right
there right
so
forty when i look at the and the 49ers
so there's nine i think there's nine
that i don't think you are you or i
would
would disagree about about relevance and
the organization gets a clue on a
year-to-year basis to where they can be
consistently a contender
or a relevant team that can build
something and sustain it in the nfl
yeah i think the cowboys do not make my
list at the end of the day the cowboys
don't and it'll be interesting to see if
tom brady is enough to make the
buccaneers truly relevant when you
consider
all the issues that have held that team
down that team has been able to and i
think the one super bowl win
that one now now it was the combination
of tony dungy putting together a great
defense and they knocked on the door and
then after they stupidly fired dungey
they had just enough of a kick in the
pants offensively put it together with
dungy's defense to win that one super
bowl if they hadn't won that one super
bowl if they didn't have that one trophy
chris i mean the buccaneers uh over the
course of the last 45 years
uh it's a joke
a grand scheme of things right from a
from an overall organizational
standpoint dysfunction on top of
dysfunction on top of dysfunction but
they have the one thing that most other
dysfunctional teams don't have they have
a super bowl trophy so they get a little
bit of a pass for that
well yeah they definitely do but you
know again i think this is where i go
back to what sean payton said i took it
more as like again the big picture of
like these are the organizations that i
think are sustained greatness goodness
you know for four or five year periods
and they have to rebuild a little bit
and they understand how to rebuild and
they're right back in the mix to me
that's how i took it with his 10 teams
yeah the bucks like they're like you
know the equivalent to like the music
industry industry right now where yeah
they're relevant this year they're a
one-hit wonder yeah i'm not gonna sit
here and put the buccaneers organization
as much as i love them and respect them
because of how they treated me in the
same class as the chiefs the patriots
the ravens the seahawks the eagles the
saints the packers the 49ers right now
so yes for this year i'm putting in
relevant but i think like in totality i
don't think they've earned that yet you
know i think the other teams that we
have to talk about that might earn that
or at least are on the fringe you know
you mentioned one the cowboys are on the
fringe how do we feel about the rams how
do we feel about the vikings i think
those are the next three teams where i
look as organizational wise to go
relevancy for a str a long stretch of
time here to where every year we go
damn they're in the mix of the playoffs
and they're in the mix for the super
bowl conversation
yeah and um
one team that that the fans are not
willing to keep in that category
uh the patriots although you and i agree
the patriots are still there we are
giving deference to what they've done
over the last 20 years i think the
absence of our franchise quarterback a
proven franchise quarterback we don't
know what jared stidham's gonna be but
the absence of that proven franchise
quarterback is enough to get a lot of
people to abandon ship although you and
i i think we agree that it's more
complicated than that there are more
factors than that and even if the
patriots dip in 2020 and don't make it
to the playoffs although i tend to think
they will
they'll they'll they'll get back up
there at some point they've got too much
between ownership front office coaching
staff and their system the patriot way
they've got too much to fall off the
face of the earth and fall into that
of 20 irrelevant teams
no exactly right and you know i mean is
anybody going to sit here and be shocked
if the patriots win the afc's this year
i'm not going to be shocked i mean am i
picking them right now probably not but
that's still the best defense in
football and they've made it better in a
lot of ways it killed it in the draft so
yeah i'm with you they might not be a
super bowl contender this year but still
i think they are very relevant and going
to be a pain in the butt and in the
conversation for the playoffs all year
long so yeah
again
it's you know we've made it we make it
again about the quarterback a little too
much at times with these conversations
too jimmy garoppolo is not one of the 10
best quarterbacks in football the 49ers
are on this list you know kirk cousins
decide build a team the team is the most
important thing then you can find the
quarterback or within building the team
you can build such a good team that the
quarterback doesn't always necessarily
need to be that big franchise i gotta
carry the squad type guy but you know
build the team first i think too many
times in the nfl we go vice versa and i
just you know again i always go back to
one of my talking points it was just
three years ago the final four had nick
foles case keenum and blake bortles okay
i mean none of those guys are anything
what we talk about franchise they had
good teams and then they found the role
within that team uh and i think the
patriots will find their way too
all right we have found our way to the
end of this edition of pft ot we'll be
back tomorrow remember i've got howard
roseman later today on pft p.m so i'm
going to ask him some tough questions
i'm going to make him sweat i'm putting
him under the hot light even though he's
on his own house i'm going to tell him
in his house chris go find a hot light
and sit under it for this interview i'm
asking the tough questions
i like it good good good job have fun
with howie how he's a great gm i'm not
necessarily in love with his draft this
year but more times than not i've been
on his side with what he does with that
organization
well they're one of the relevant teams
and he's one of the reasons why and i'll
break down all the picks with him and
all the moves they made and we'll do
that later today on pft pm we'll see you
tomorrow for another edition of pft live
everybody have a great tuesday see you
tomorrow
see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports